اهلا بكم قال الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان ان حزب الاتحاد الديمقراطي الكردي
السوري وافق على دخول 1300 من مقاتلي او
مسلحي الجيش السوري الحر الى مدينه عين
عرب كوباني نتوقف مع هذا الخبر نناقشه في
محورين ماذا يعني كل هذا الاهتمام من
العالم بما يجري في عين العرب كوباني دون
غيرها من المناطق
السوريه وهل وضع المدنيين في المناطق
الاخرى في سوريا خارج الحسابات
الدوليه انظار العالم مركزه على عين العرب
كوبني رغم البؤر العديد الاكثر سخونه
والاشد الما منها فيما يتعلق بوضع
المدنيين في سوريا واقع يثير تساؤلات
عديده عن المستفيد الاكبر من تشتيت
الاعلام بعيدا عن الجرائم التي يرتكبها
النظام السوري في حلب وحمص وريفها وريف
دمشق تقرير زياد
بركات لا ترى عيون العالم سوى عين العرب
كوباني على شاشات التلفزه في المؤتمرات في
لقاءات الساسه عبر العالم كله ثمه وحسب
عين العرب كوباني حتى انها اصبحت مهنه من
لا مهنه له ياتون الى التلال القريبه منها
ويتابعون حربا تجري امامهم كانها تبث
مباشره على الهواء على شاكله تلفزيون
الواقع منذ نحو شهر والتحالف الدولي يشن
غارات شبه يوميه على مسلحي تنظيم الدوله
هناك اوباما يلتقي قاده عسكريين من 20
دوله لبحث الموقف وثم متابعات حثيثه وعلى
مدار الساعه لكل متر يتقدم فيه مسلحو
الدوله داخل المدينه بالتزامن مع جهود
محمومه تبذل لتسليح وحدات حمايه الشعب
الكردي وهو ما ادخل علاقه الولايات
المتحده بتركيا في ازمه لم تعد صامته
واشنطن تريد من انقره تسهيل دخول مقاتلين
اكراد من العراق الى المدينه للقتال والى
ان يحدث هذا يلقي التحالف جوا اسلحه
وذخائر للاكراد بعضها للمفارق يسقط في
ايدي مسلحي الدوله لا احد يتحدث عن الظلال
التي تمنح الصوره قواما مختلفا ومغاير
فالبلد خلت من سكانها او كادت قبل بدء
الغارات نحو 200 ال غادروها واصبحوا امنين
في تركيا ومن بقي فيها اكراد مسلحون
يتطلعون الى ما هو ابعد من حمايتها امر
يفسر عدم الحديث عن ضحايا مدنيين هناك
واقتصاره على قتلى في صفوف مسلحي الدوله
والاهم ان دخان القصف غطى ويغطي ماساه
تتواصل في بقيه المدن السوريه فلا احد
يكترث او يدعو لتحالف من اي نوع لمواجهه
ازدياد الغارات الحكوميه على حلب وريف
دمشق وبقيه المدن هناك فقد شهد هذا الشهر
تزايدا غير مسبوق لعدد الغارات والبراميل
المتفجره وحصار يشتد اطباقا على بعض
المناطق يجري كل هذا بصمت اقرب الى
التواطئ او التناغم فالعين التي ترى مسلحي
تنظيم الدوله وهم يقتلون ويقتلون ويقاتلون
في عين العرب كوباني وهي مدينه سوريه لا
تريد ان ترى قوات الاسد وهي تفعل الشيء
نفسه في بقيه مدن
البلاد الليله نناقشه مع ضيوفنا من
اسطنبول الدكتور خالد خوجه سفير الائتلاف
الوطني السوري في تركيا ومن واشنطن السفير
ادم ايرلي الناطق باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه سابقا ومن بروكسل عبر سكايب مع
الكاتب الصحفي هوشنك اوسي اهلا بضيوفي
الكرام وابدا بالسيد ايرلي لاساله او انقل
له تساؤل الرئيس التركي عندما تساءل لماذا
كل هذا الاهتمام الامريكي والتحرك الدولي
فيما يجري بكوباني مع انه لا يوجد مدنيون
في
كوباني اعتقد اننا في
كوباني لدينا محاوله استراتيجيه من قبل
الدوله
الاسلاميه لضمان مواقعها في شمال سوريا
فاذا ما استولوا على
كوباني يكون عند ذاك عندهم خط امدادات
مستمر واعاده التزود بالمؤن والذخائر
وسيكونوا يكونون بذلك قوه اكثر قدره على
القتال
للتصدي وللقيام بحكم شمال سوريا والتصدي
لمناورات جيتهم تقول على اساسي انهم اذا
ما استطاعوا السيطره على كوباني قدراتهم
ستضخ وتزداد لهذا السبب من الاهميه بمكان
ايقافهم المشكله للتركي ان كوباني تقع على
حدودها مباشره فلديهم الكثير من المصلحه
والاهتمام في نتائج هذه المعركه مما سيجعل
وطبعا هي منطقه مهمه لان حزب العمال
الكردستاني نشط فيها منذ فتره ويسبب
الكثير من المشكلات تركيا لذلك هناك
حساسيات تركيا لا علاقه لها بالدوله
الاسلاميه وهذا ما يصعب من موقف سيد ادم
ايرلي اذا كان الوضع بهذه الحساسيه وبهذه
الاستراتيجيه اذا لماذا قال وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي بان واشنطن سوف تحاول ان تضعف
تنظيم الدوله في سوريا ولكنها ستقاتل
بشراسه التنظيم في
العراق عليك قتالها في كلا
الدولتين و انا لا اريد ان ابالغ واضيف
الى ما تصريحات كلمه ليس فيها اذا ما اردت
التصدي لتنظيم الدوله عليك ان تحاربها
بضراوه في كلا الدولتين المشكله التركيز
الحالي لمعركه ونقطه التركيز هي كوباني
ربما ستتحول نقطه التركيز الى منطقه اخرى
في
العراق مثلا اذا عندما كانت كان تنظيم
الدوله يتقدم نحو بغداد ويشكل خطرا على
مطارها كان هناك ضروره للتصدي لهم اذا
كوباني ليست منطقه القتال الوحيده لكن
وجود الدوله الاسلاميه وقدراتها يعني ان
علينا ان نحاربهم في كل الجبهات وفي كل
الاوقات دكتور خالد خوجه الرئيس التركي
ايضا قال بانه تم الاتفاق على ادخال 1300
من عناصر الجيش السوري الحر حتى يقاتلوا
في كوباني بينما الاكراد نقلا عن السيد
مسلم الاتحاد الكردي يعني قال بان التفاوض
مازال مستمرا ما الذي يجري يعني حتى يتم
التفاوض عن دخول قوات لتساعد المقاتلين في
كوباني حتى يواجهوا تنظيم الدوله ما الذي
يجري لا واضح جدا ان حزب الاتحاد
الديمقراطي بزعامه صالح مسلم لا يريد ابدا
تواجد قوات غير قوات حزب الاتحاد
الديمقراطي في في المنطقه وهو يريد
ان يحظى بالدعم الاكبر من الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه في حربه ضد تنظيم داعش
ليس فقط لا يريد عناصر الجيش الحر وانما
قبل ساعه من الان كان هناك تفاوض على ان
تدخل قوات من الباشمركتيرة
وقد وافق عليها سابقا حزب الاتحاد
الديمقراطي ولكن تم تخفيض هذا العدد من
قبل الحزب الى 150 يعني رفض 50 عضو اخر من
الباش مركا وهم قوات كرديه من الواضح جدا
ان حزب الاتحاد الديمقراطي يريد ان يقوي
نفوذه في تلك المنطقه ويريد ان يحظى على
المقدار الاوفر من الدعم الامريكي طيب
فيما يتعلق ايضا بالاهتمام الامريكي
والدولي فيما يجري بكوباني مق قه مع ما
يجري في مناطق سوريه اخرى السيد ايرلي يرى
بان كوباني نقطه استراتيجيه وبالتالي ان
تمكن منها تنظيم الدوله فسوف يتمكن من
كامل شمال سوريا هل تجد هذا هو السبب
الاساسي في هذا الاهتمام الامريكي بما
يجري في كوباني وهذا تدخل وهذا
الضغط اعتقد يجب ان نكون صريحين لم يكن
احد يسمع حتى بكلمه كوباني قبل قرار قوات
التحالف قوات
التحالف هجوم على تنظيم داعش في سوريا
والعراق كان من المقرر ان يكون هناك ضربات
جويه في سوريا والعراق ولكن على المنطقتين
الرقه ودير الزور التي تتواجد فيها عناصر
داعش بكثافه في اليومين الاولين تم ضرب
اهداف في المنطقه الاستراتيجيه الاكثر
اهميه هي دير الزور والرقه وثم تم تخفيض
هذه الهجمات الجويه واتجه الامر الى
كوباني كوباني من ناحيه الاستراتيجيه هي
اقل منطقه استراتيجيه من حيث تواجد داعش
وداعش لا لا يوجد فيها عناصر كثيرون في
منطقه كوباني داعش يعني مركز داعش في
سوريا هو معروف في في من الرقه وفي دير
الزور المشكله ان الاداره الامريكيه رفضت
ان تكون هناك
استراتيجيه واضحه في محاربه داعش في سوريا
كالتي في العراق واضح ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تعاملت في العراق مع قوات بريه
ب سواء ب
بوجود قوات الباشمركتيرة
تضخيم
ل اهميه الاستراتيجيه لمنطقه كوبانيا
ويبدو ان المساله ليست هي داعش بقدر ما هي
تعزيز نفوز حزب الاتحاد الديمقراطي في تلك
المنطقه السيد هوشين اوسي ضيفي من بروكسل
اذا كان الهدف هو ايقاف تنظيم الدوله
ومواجهته اذا لماذا يصبح موضوع دخول قوات
من الجيش السوري الحر للمقاتله الى جانبكم
مساله تحتاج الى ت
بتقديري ان منطقه كوباني هي منطقه مهمه
ولها يعني اهميه استراتيجيه ليس فقط
بالنسبه للاكراد انما بالنسبه لداعش
وداعش تركز بشكل كبير واستراتيجي على
منطقه كوباني على مدى ليس فقط الشهر
المنصرم بل على مدى سنه من الحصار لو كانت
كوباني ليست مهمه بالنسبه لداعش
كانت لما كانت استخدمت قوات من ريف حلب
ومن من الرقه ومن كل المناطق لقي يعني
السؤال الذي ينبغي ان يطرح لماذا اصرار
داعش على منطقه كوباني في هذه الحاله س
سيد اوسي ما الذي يختلف بين دير الزور او
الرقه او كوبني حتى يتم كل هذا التركيز
على كوبني واهتمام اقل من قبل المجتمع
الدولي وقوه التحالف على ما جرى في دير
الزور او الرقه او مناطق اخرى لا المجتمع
الدولي اتم منذ اربع سنوات بشكل او باخر
بالمس السوريه عموما وبالمدن السوريه بشكل
عام مجزره الغوطه وكل المزاز والمناطق
التي شملها ارهاب واجرام النظام الاسدي
انما التقليل من اهميه
كوباني والتشكيك في الاهتمام الدولي
بمساله كوباني كما اتى عليه ضيفكم من من
من تركيا فهو ينسجم تماما مع
المطلب التركي يعني كل التقارير
الاستخباريه والاعلاميه وحتى تصريحات
المسؤولين الامريكيين والاوروبيين اشاروا
الى تورط وضلوع تركيا في هذا الهجوم
الداعشي على منطقه كوباني اصرار داعش على
منطقه كوباني هو في الاصل اصرار
تركي يعني انجاز التعبير ما الذي يؤكد ذلك
ما الذي يؤكد ذلك سيد سيد
اوسي يعني الذي يؤكد ذلك معظم التقارير
التي تناول الصحافه الغربيه دير شبيجل
وواشنطن بوست نيويورك تايمز النائب الرئيس
الامريكي صرح بتورط وضلوع تركيا حتى
الصحافه التركيه نفسها اشارت الى انه ابو
بكر البغدادي كان يتواجد في تركيا في سنه
2008 وهو على علاقه مع الاستخبارات
التركيه وهذا هذا ما نشرته الصحافه
التركيه يعني هنالك شيء من التعميه
والتعتيم على الضلوع والدور التركي في دعم
داعش وهجوم داعش على منطقه كوباني عبر
تقليل من اهميه هذه المدينه عبر التقليل
من من مقاومه المقاتلين الاكراد
عبر التضخيم في مساله يعني الجيش الحر
لماذا لم يكن يفتح جبهات في منطقه منبج
وجرابلس بما انه منط داعش صحبت قواتها من
هناك وزجت بثقلها العسكري الان في منطقه
كوباني داعش لا تحارب نظام الاسد ولا
تحارب جيش الحر الان داعش تركز على منطقه
كوباني ومقاومه كوباني التي هزت
العالم يعني هؤلاء المقاتلين الابطال
صمدوا امام هذا التنظيم الدولي الارهابي
لمده شهر ولا زالوا صامدين في وقت عجز جيش
النظام الاسدي وعجز حتى الجيش الحر وعجز
الجيش المالكي في في الصمود امام هذا
التنظيم الارهابي الدولي ل لبضعه ايام
يعني
ف المساله انه المقاتلين الاكراد
يرفضون دخول الجيش الحر هذا عاري عن الصحه
عفوا خليني اكمل هذا عالي عن الصرحه بدليل
مازلت معنا على كل حال مازلت معنا وساعود
لك مازلت معنا سيد اوصي فيما يتعلق بهذ
الحلقه مضمون هذه الحلقه سيد ادم ايرلي
فيما يختلف الاكراد
والامريكيون طبعا غير المعلن فيما يتعلق
بالوضع في كوباني سواء كان تحت سيطره
تنظيم الدوله او استعادها الاكراد او
المقاتلون اعتقد ان من الاهميه بمكان
طالما نحن نتناقش في هذا الموضوع ان نضع
الامور في سياقها الصحيح النقاش يتعلق
بالتكتيك والجانب التعبوي وليس الجانب
الاستراتيجي السؤال عندما نقول لماذا
كوباني وليس الرقه وليس دير الزور اذا كنت
تحضر مباراه كره قدم تقول لماذا مررت
الكره لهذا اللاعب او لذلك اللاعب حقيقه
الموضوع وكنه الموضوع يبقى و ان هذه هي
حمله عسكريه والخبراء العسكريون هم الذين
يقررون ما هي الطريقه الافضل لالحاق
الهزيمه بالعدو لايقاف زحف تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه واعادته الى الوراء ولكي ولكن
سيد سيد ادم
ايرلي سيد ايرلي هل تعتقد بان الرئيس
التركي يشاهد عفوا هل تعتقد بان الرئيس
التركي يشاهد مباراه قدم عندما يطرح مثل
هذا التساؤل لماذا كل هذا الاهتمام
بكوباني بينما يعاني السوريون في مناطق
عدوي بشكل
فظيع اعتقد ان رئيس تركيا يعاني من من
تناقض لانه يواجه تهديد من جهتين تهديد
الدوله الاسلاميه من جهه يؤسس وجودا قويا
على حدود بلاده وهو في نفس الوقت يواجه
تهديد تمرد كردي داخل بلده اذا المهم امام
رئيس تركيا هو كيف يحمي بلده من كلا
التهديد التمرد الكردي وتهديد الدوله
الاسلاميه مشكله في كوباني اذا انك اذا
اردت ان تلحق الهزيمه بالدوله الاسلاميه
عليك ان تساعد الاكراد الذين قد يحاربون
الاتراك غدا اذا انا اقدر هذا الوضع الصعب
والمز الذي يجد نفسه فيه اما من وجهه نظر
الولا المتحده المهمه رقم واحد هي وقف حد
لتقدم تنظيم الدوله في كوباني لكي لا
يستخدمها كقاعده لمهاجمه تركيا او العراق
هذه هي معضله الرئيس التركي حاليا طيب في
هذه اذا كان المنطق العسكري الاستراتيجي
الامريكي على هذا المنوال اذا لماذا لم
يتم مساعده الجيش الحر بنفس الطريقه وهو
يحارب تنظيم الدوله منذ
شهور
اولا انا اختلف مع القول باننا لا نساعد
الجيش السوري الات المتحده تدفع المال
وتعطيهم السلاح لكل العناصر التي تحارب
الاسد وتحارب الدوله الاسلاميه بما في ذلك
الجيش السوري الحر لكن حقيقه الامر اننا
نتحدث عن كوباني شمال سيريا هي منطقه
الجيش السوري الحر ليس قوه فيها القوه على
الارض هناك ليست الجيش السوري الحر اذا
اردت ان تحارب تنظيم الدوله في كوبان عليك
ان تساع الاكراد فهم الذين موجودون على
الارض هناك بعد الفاصل سوف نناقش الاهتمام
العالمي فيما يجري في عين العرب كوباني
دون غيرها من المناطق السوريه هل معنى ذلك
بان بقيه المناطق خارج الحسابات حسابات
قوات
التحالف اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه
التي تناقش الاهتمام العالمي فيما يجري في
عين العرب كوباني دون غيرها من المناطق في
سوريا دكتور خالد خوجه استمعت الى م قاله
السيد ادم يرلي في تحليل ما يجري ان من
يحددون هم قاده عسكريون يتابعون هل انتم
مع هذا الطرح فيما يتعلق بالمقارنه بين ما
يجري من تعامل مع الوضع في كوباني ومناطق
اخرى في داخل
سوريا اولا موضوع اهميه كوباني اكيد
بمقدار ما تعطيها الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه من اهميه تعطيها داعش نفس
الاهميه اصبحت الاهميه معنويه اكثر منها
استراتيجيه داعش تريد ان تكسر شوكه
التحالف في كوباني والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تريد ان يعني ان تقلل من من قوه
داعش في تلك المنطقه
وبالتالي تريد ان تحرز
تقدما في حربها ضد داعش ولكن ليست هنا
المساله المساله ان في الحرب والتوجيه
الانظار نحو كوباني تجري هناك يجري هناك
اداره انطباع ال على على محورين المحور
الاول هو اي
ان الحرب هي الحرب الشعب السوري بين بين
داعش وبين الشعب السوري او بين داعش وبين
الاكراد وهو ليس صحيحا انما الحرب هي
الجرائم الحقيقيه التي بداها النظام
السوري بالتعاون مع حزب الاتحاد
الديمقراطي في المناطق الشماليه اي ال
المحور الاخر هو ان الاكراد هم مختصر في
حزب الاتحاد الديمقراطي بينما هناك 13
فصيل كردي منضوي تحت مظله الائتلاف الوطني
لقوى الثوره والمعارضه السوريه
هذا هذا التحالف الكردي واجه الويلات من
حزب الاتحاد الديمقراطي والجميع يذكر
مجزره عامود التي كان المعتصمون في في
عمود النشطاء يعتصمون وجر اطلاق طيب دكتور
خالد هل ه هل لديكم عفوا هل لديكم تفسير
لهذا التركيز الامريكي بشكل اكبر وبطرق
مختلفه ومستوى ضغط اكبر فيما يجري في
كوباني بالمقارنه مع مناطق سوريه اخرى هل
لديكم تفسير لهذا السلوك الامريكي او قوه
التحالف انا انا انا لا لنفرض جدلا ان ان
الاداره الامريكيه لا تريد ان تضرب الاسد
وقد صرحوا اكثر من من مره
اي لذلك لن اتحدث حدث عن الاهميه
الاستراتيجيه لمنطقه القصير كما كانت
السنه الماضيه او القلمون او حتى حلب
نتحدث الان عن اهميه الاستراتيجيه بالنسبه
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه في ضرب داعش
داعش متواجده بقوه عاصمه داعش هي الرقه
ودير الزور وهناك يجري تماس مباشره بين
تلك المدينتين الحدوديتين وبين داعش في
العراق فهي تحصل على الدعم باستمرار وكذلك
الدعم المتبادل بين الرقه ودير الزور وبين
المناطق المتواجده عليها فيها داعش في
العراق لذلك الاهميه الاستراتيجيه للرقه
والدير زور اكبر بكثير وهناك يتواجد الجيش
الحر يمكن دعم الجيش الحر في حلب والمناطق
الشماليه لمحاربه داعش في تلك المنطقه
وبالتالي تصبح داعش محاصره تماما في منطقه
كوباني الجميع يعرف ذلك ولكن و وبالتالي
يمكن القضاء على داعش في تلك المنطقه ولكن
يبدو ان
يعني الاداره الامريكيه لا تفكر بهذه
الطريقه تفكر فعلا باحراز تقدم ما ضد داعش
ولكن بابقاء الامور كما هي انا اعتقد ان
ال ال الغايه منها خلق نموذج حوثيون جدد
في المناطق الشماليه السوريه بقياده حزب
الاتحاد الديمقراطي سيد هوشين اوسي هناك
ايضا من يقول متابعه الوضع في كوباني بان
لو ارادت واشنطن وقوات التحالف بان تضبط
الوضع في كوباني وتجعل وتجبر قوات تنظيم
الدوله على التراجع لفعلت ولكن ايضا
واشنطن لها حساباتها فيما يتعلق بكوباني
هل انت مع هذا الطرح لا انا لست مع هذا
الطرح اي من جهه اخرى من جهه اخرى مساله
تشويه المقاومه البطوليه والتاريخيه التي
هزت عالم العالم وعواصم الغرب مقاومه
كوباني من يشو من
يشو من قبل ضيفكم في اسطنبول يعني اي هذا
يدعو للخجل والخزي والعار يعني الائتلاف
الوطني السوري كان ينبغي عليه ان يطالب ان
يطالب التحالف الدولي لانقاذ كوباني لا ان
ولكن ضيفنا من اسطنبول قال لا يجب حصر من
يقاتلون في كوباني فقط في الاتحاد
الديمقراطي هناك فصائل كرديه اخرى وهناك
عناصر من الجيش الحر ايضا يقاتلون في
كوباني هل في هذا تشويه يا سيدي خلي ضيفك
في اسطنبول يرد علي انت انت تدير الحوار
وتدير انا لا ارد عليك انا اقول كما قال
ضيف وهذا دوري هو من حقه ان يرد ومن حقي
ان ان ارد هذا من جهه من جهه اخرى
المقاتلين الكرد ينسقون وهنالك كتائب من
الجيش الحر موجوده في كوباني وتقاتل الى
جانب المقاتلين الاكراد حسنا فعلت امريكا
بانها لن تنصت للائتلاف ولن تنصت لتركيا و
وليس الائتلاف وتركيا من يحدد لولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ما ينبغي عليها ان تفعل
ومن عليها ان تسلح منذ اربع سنوات من يسلح
الجيش الحر من يقدم له الاموال اليست الا
الاوال والاسلحه
الامريكيه اذا كان الرئيس التركي يطالب
يطالب التحالف الغربي بدعم وهذا مطلب
مشروع ومطلب انا قبل اي شخص اطالب بدعم
الجيش الحر فل تفتح تركيا مخازن اسلحتها
للجيش الحر لماذا لا تفتح تركيا مخازنها
للجيش الحر لماذا لا تدعمهم بمناى عن
الاداره الامريكيه وتتخذ هذا الموقف طالما
هي مع الجيش الحر وطالما ان تركيا مع
اسقاط نظام الاسد وهي صديقه الشعب الكردي
يعني مساله تشويه المقاومه الكرديه وتشويه
اكراد هذه مهمه ليست مهمه الائتلاف الوطني
السوري اللعب على التناقضات بين الفصائل
الكرديه ليست مهمه ض انتهى وقت البرنامج
سيد اوشي هوشين اوسي كنت ضيفنا من بروكسل
كما اشكر ضيفي من اسطنبول الدكتور خالد
خوجه سفير الائتلاف الوطني السوري في
تركيا ومن واشنطن اشكر ضيفي السفير ادم
ايرلي الناطق باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه سابقا الى
اللقاء